I think it's stupid Dionne Warwick
reacts to hearing the news her late
cousin Whitney Houston is set to go on
tour via hologram
I'm having a clue as to what that is
it's surprising to me too it was
announced on Monday seven years after
Whitney's death that a holographic
theatrical concept of her will be going
on tour I don't know what it is I think
it's stupid whatever it is that's what
it is Dionne also addressed her recent
interview with Essence magazine where
she questioned Beyonce status as an icon
she told the publication that although
she admires Queen Bee
she is doubtful as to whether or not her
career will reach the level of success
that musicians like Frank Sinatra and
Patti LaBelle have everything that who I
consider icons in the industry worked
very hard and they have garnered the
support of people who have supported
them over the years and there's one or
two or ten or twelve but twenty years
nothing about 50 60 70 80 years people
who have really earned that status he
was with the 78 year old singer at the
community anti-drug coalition's of
America's first annual second-chance
digital impact recipient Awards this
called second chance and fortunately we
have people who are ready to do
something about this opioid and other
drugs that are taking a baby especially
out not to mention the older folks who
have been unfortunately subjected to
becoming just tied to these drugs and
it's a pleasure to be a part of this you
know help has been oh it's one of my
mainstays
very diligently with many many other
avenues health but this is something
that's very important and it's
dominating the headlines today children
are being caught up it's something that
they have no business being caught up in
and unfortunately it happens at the top
which is their parents who are running
with addictions to this ugliness you
know drug companies have got to be kind
of put on notice as well how important
is it for you just to lend your voice
and be here today of course for all
these people I'm hoping that it helps
you know and I know it's something that
I would definitely advocate and would
love to get more people involved